Automatic packaging is one of the strange patterns in your application.
Sometimes it is not really a performance problem
But when they are, they consume memory and performance.
My name is Colt McCannless, thanks to the Android operating environment
You can avoid one of the biggest causes of automatic packaging problems - HashMap containers
Now, automatic packaging is a process in which the operating environment automatically converts
One of the initial patterns to the corresponding public object pattern.
But this is bad for two reasons.
The first reason is that the packaging is automatic
A customization of an Integer object will generate any type of conversion that it uses.
Second, these general organisms are larger than their primary counterparts,
16 bytes for a valid object instead of 4 for the initial interview.
Meaning not only because it allocates objects
But these objects are much larger than they should be.
Now, this is not a big problem for your intermediate calculations,
But the time you get,
Is when dealing with public containers such as HashMap.
Note, when using primitive styles, such as int, float, and bool,
HashMap must use object versions.
So instead of being able to use a simple 32-bit int
HashMap is forced to use general Integer objects
Which of course consumes more memory.
And you have to be careful here
Because any time you call it an initial pattern from a public container,
You get automatic packaging process.
Now, memory is very important in Android and to save space is running Android
Providing a whole family of public containers built specifically to secure the work of HashMap
But allow you to use the initial patterns and avoid automatic packaging.
Welcome to SparseArray family of scattered matrices.
Basically the scattered matrices are similar to ArrayMaps
So that they reduce the overall memory effect
By using two closely interconnected matrices rather than one large matrix for hashing.
But they also cause some extra effort to bring the kettles.
So they are actually useful for containers containing only hundreds of objects
Instead of thousands or millions.
The main difference between scattered arrays and ArrayMaps is that it is in scattered matrices
The key object is always a defined primary style instead of a generic style,
Allowing you to save memory and avoid automatic packaging.
But in fact, the differences stop there.
Like ArrayMaps, you can also cross scattered matrices by indexing
Instead of using an iterative pattern, it is required for HashMaps
Also significantly slower and consumes more memory to do.
And also like ArrayMaps
It is not wise to use the beds of improved scattered matrix containers in each case.
But there are some ideal cases to consider.
First, situations where you have a few items, almost in the hundreds
It has lots of access, or access operations that are rarely repeated
So that the extra effort to bring the elements is not noticeable.
Secondly, where we have containers of maps,
Often a map is a map of a map
The sub-maps are the deeper they are in the stack
Tend to contain a smaller number of elements,
We end up passing through these sub-maps many times.
If your use cases do not fall into either of these situations
It may be best to stick to using the HashMap row
Instead of one of these wonderful and beautiful alternatives.
It highlights every interesting point,
Improving performance is a trade-off of searches on the right container
For proper usage mode for the correct memory cases.
As one of them said, there is no magic solution,
That's why you need to check the rest of the content of Android performance patterns.
For more information on these types of swaps.
Do not forget to join our community on Google+ too,
To hear war stories from other developers.
So stay calm, type your code, and always remember, performance is important.